[Music]
and embarrassing punishment news Oh
submitted by your northern neighbor a
judge slams two men for falsely claiming
veteran status a judge slams stolen
Balor man like gravity's hair full of
[ __ ] is not too likely like put them
in their place kind of I got it know
what talks like that here player got
[ __ ] hardshell tacos and crushed the
moister becomes like sony saying because
Mexicans breathe through their nose you
breathe through your mouth mouth you're
supposed to breathe through your nose
they bring a visa you're a bro from the
like Taco Bell dog know the guy that
plays the voice of that guy avid wool we
hate that guy he's actually mo second
though okay
so a judge ordered two men to write down
the names of all 6756 Americans I have
been killed in Afghanistan and Iraq
before they become eligible for parole
so they were falsely claiming that they
were veterans themselves in order to get
a lesser sentence and go to like the
veteran's prison or lay off a judge but
then they found out that obviously
they're lying about serving and so that
they get a worse sentence they got an
even more son why even do that because
you know you're gonna get found out yeah
thirty in front of a judge they're in
the system they're gonna find out
everything about me
so this weird um I know they are on top
you don't know unless you try true on
top of handwriting the the names of six
thousand Americans they also have to
hand write obituaries of the forty
Montanans killed in Iraq and Afghanistan
and those words good they also have to
wear a placard at Montana Veterans
Memorial every Memorial and Veterans Day
that read
beware of yes I like this meeting punish
this judges tight what's a better is the
judge oh yeah this is like Veterans
Court legally cuz they have their own I
want that exact piece of paper laminated
and on top of that I wonder what the
placard is gonna look like they have to
well I guess like that is it like super
[ __ ] heavy like is it gonna be in
camouflage they also have to write gonna
see it true
they'll have to write letters of apology
to multiple American veteran
organizations and they have to serve 441
hours of community stay and wall dude
6000 names you have to they have to
write 6,000 names by hand yeah no enter
no can you imagine like it took me like
forever to write like a hundred
invitations for our wedding it like
that's that's a long time writing 6000
names their heads gonna be all [ __ ] up
yeah they're gonna give that bump like
on there and you can't use cursive
either they also have to write
obituaries for 40 oh my gosh
I mean I love this punishment but I'm
just like wow that I mean to put in
perspective that's why would you pretend
yeah so Ryan who's 28 was sentenced to
10 years of prison for violating
probation for felony burglary and Troy
33 it was sentenced to five years for a
drug possession and then on top of all
that that's when they said they're
saying that the judge suspended three
years of each of their sentences but
issued that variance to each of them
before they're eligible for parole so
these are the guys
shovelry yeah that's a good question
mrs. Troi and this is right
Stolen Valor yeah exactly I don't know
you could look like that in jail I
thought you had to shave everything
before yeah it doesn't look like they
using a jumpsuit there's a there's a guy
that goes around and he catches all
these like fake veterans online like I
guess there's like homeless people or
just random people that wear like fake
outfits too and then just they go to
these like Memorial Day festivals and
get like discounts and just all kinds of
weird things yeah you'll catch them
you'll be like oh really what what were
you in what was this and who was your
unit and what was the end and I'm like I
how does he know who's faking wrong they
can tell by the stories oh like a kid
know like how much fake there is behind
the pride so I can just go up to anybody
or they'll be wearing oh no I think
they'll like wear different pieces of
uniform like true veterans have them oh
yeah or like they're wearing a uniform
that's like been outdated forever but
they're young because they don't know
like if you're in the military and
you're really like and you understand
all of it why is this marine wearing a
navy is it guys uniform or like during
this during this war they didn't wear
there's already switch to this new oh no
they can look at it and go this is
already this is [ __ ] can you tell
from being in the military can you I
could tell certain things from certain
periods but since I'm not like like a
historian or like someone that's really
into the history of military I don't
know all the phases of uniform but like
for for guns for example like like
rifles I knew every phase that when we
trained in so like if I saw like a
certain like aro air from oh that's from
the Vietnam War era or if I saw another
awesome the Korean War because we we do
study a bit of like war history but not
all of it like I'm not I'm not familiar
all across the board with Air Force Army
and Navy but you also understand like
hierarchy structure units yeah yeah yeah
whatever those words are ready like like
this guy that's how he catches them
he'll be like all right so who's what
unit were you in or whatever and
probably study Sam
converse don't 151 and then dua 151 huh
yeah if you have a conversation with
someone and like and under like 15-20
minutes and if you talk enough and if
you're out to get people you could
probably fish it out does she feel like
make them doubt themselves all these
people trying to get free chicken
sandwiches on Memorial Day mmm
watch out so the guy with the beard he
said that he did seven combat tours in
2016 Oh crazy and he lied that means he
would have had tours although until 2023
you know that why is that always most
people only have one combat tour a year
and because a tour last six to eight
months unless you're like a super duper
ooper Navy SEAL and they're flying back
constantly he wouldn't be fat like that
dude if it was a super duper food for
navies he also lied that he was injured
by a bomb where and then he got off that
with community service so the reason why
these guys are lying is lightweight so
they could get their criminal seven
combat tours yeah it's so the reason why
they lied is so they could get their
criminal cases transferred to Veterans
Court where vets get a more lenient
treatment because of the service that
they have had and the lingering effects
of PTSD and that's the reason why these
guys thought they were so smart so most
people have a single enlistment which is
a four-year term in the four-year term
most people have one maybe to combat
combat tours so him just outright coming
out with seven it's like it who's who's
the fakir who faking it and then and
then everyone's like one or two
someone's like let's see I don't know
the other services but let's say he
[ __ ] that he was a Marine all right
I had like like three enlistments then
in the Marine Corps as soon as you're
done with your first enlistment you have
to go to this thing called the B billet
which you have to become a recruiter or
drone struktur or serve at an embassy
which means you're not gonna be going to
a combat tour in the middle cuz you're
out you're picking up a second job
that's not your original job so
after comet can't go back don't though
they'll make you do like some guarding
or something well they want you to do
like a different service so you under
you better understand the Marine Corps
but I thought the Marine Corps Norfolk I
don't know how Navy or Army they might
have other things but so while you're
and be billet you can't be on combat can
you eventually go back out to combat
yeah yeah yeah after your be billet is
over then people so like my my old
recruiter he was infantry then while he
was a recruiter he was just getting new
recruits to join the Marine Corps and
then as soon as recruiting Duty was over
he can wait to go back out that's what
he'd like to do yeah anyone back out and
he did infantry so at the time I was
kind of like in between like Army and
Marine Corps cuz I went to like a
military school and then there were more
army based and then but I always had
this notion that like out of the boot
camps and with my very elementary
knowledge of the military I knew the
Marine Corps was the hardest not knowing
that there are the things like special
operations I Navy SEALs and Army Rangers
and other stuff so I just knew the first
preliminary boot camp that the Marine
Corps is the hardest and the longest so
I went to go talk to an army recruiter
and the way he talked to me he was like
trying to sell me this dream like it was
like a used car salesman like this guy's
vibes I went next door to the Marine
Corps one on mic hello and no one was
even there and then I was like knocking
on the door and finally like I see this
sleeping bag move from underneath the
desk and this guy wakes up goes oh [ __ ]
he's like you want to Marine Corps Mike
this is my people this guy didn't give a
[ __ ] he was just so [ __ ] real he
wasn't even in his uniform like you had
to sell him and with him on you he was
just on in a t-shirt and he was like oh
she won't let me get my [ __ ] ready and
I'm like oh this guy's really real and
then when I started talking to oh my
this is dope cuz I like I think Marines
they don't have to have I don't get this
sense if they have something to prove
you know he's like I'm a badass
[ __ ] all you want to join us
that's cool versus the army one is like
oh you know but we could do this and and
then do this and just felt like he's
like too thirsty yeah that's why I Drive
yeah that is pretty funny so because of
the schools you went that's why you
narrowed it down to those two yeah I
don't know too much about the Navy and
then I didn't know too much about the
airforce either what about the Coast
Guard I don't know too much about the
Coast Guard either I don't know anything
about that cause Clark the Air Force you
do know you get to be the planes or I
don't care about playing that's cool
that's the reason why but now looking
back well I quit with all the things
that I know so like some of the I think
the best pilots are action in the Navy
yeah which is like counterintuitive
because then they fly off the aircraft
carriers I can Top Gun but now knowing I
think the two routes I would have gone
there's two routes because I would have
probably done special operations of some
sort one is in the Air Force and they
have the top
they're called paratroopers so they are
the drop like life savers in the world
so when Navy SEALs get in trouble these
guys go in and jump in and save them Wow
they never get to do anything because
they're like top top top top top oh well
they do the dopest [ __ ] they do this so
it's like usually the SEAL team and the
SEAL team don't have like a paratrooper
with them and the other one is this is
where my Asian side kicks in I would
have been an Army Ranger because out of
the all the Special Ops they have the
shortest pipeline so you don't have to
go through as many schools but then you
get to do a lot of cool [ __ ] because
they have because it's so short like to
become a Navy SEAL it's like it's a long
time three years of back to back to back
to back training as the same thing with
Special Forces it's like a long time but
then for Rangers you just have to go to
the army boot camp which is already
short then you go to jump school which
is like another like four weeks and then
you go to Ranger School which is like
another like eight weeks so within like
half a year you could become our Army
Ranger pretty much yeah that's what I
would fight their code
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]